foreign
[Music]
another topic that I get a lot of
questions about a lot of my fans
listening and watching you will want to
know something you don't really talk
that much about you probably have a
video about it we'll get to your video
uh over and your your catalog in in a
bit but uh and that's aliens uh which
which are in the news almost every day
now uh ranging from you know people like
past guest Tom Delong you know claiming
he has recovered uh you know the
portions of an alien spaceship when he
came on my podcast uh which was quite uh
quite interesting to to go down the
rabbit Hall with him and find out
actually he can't verify exactly that
he's owned it anyway uh but he is I give
him credit he brought a lot of this you
know he was a musician for this band
Blink 182 he lives in San Diego great
guy fun guy but you know he kind of got
this into the attention of the media uh
about five six years ago and now it's
risen all the way up to my friend and uh
and colleague and and president of the
Simons Foundation uh Professor David
spurtle and David is now co-leading this
NASA panel commissioned by the the chief
administrator on down to investigate the
role of what they call a uaps the
unidentified aerial phenomena but that
could include UFOs objects they could
include evidence and data of course I've
had on Avi Loeb and and other people uh
as well but I wanna I haven't asked you
about this um where do you come down do
you do you believe that there are uh you
know credible uh bits of evidence
suggesting that Earth well first of all
the aliens exist uh other life forms
exist let's start there do you think
life exists outside of the earth and is
that a scientific question or is it a
faith-based question well we don't
actually have any evidence that life
exists elsewhere so
um at this point I would say it's a
faith-based question
um so if you want to know what I believe
I believe the answer is yes
um that's mostly because I I think that
it isn't as difficult to create complex
complexity
um our sponsors like to think I think
physicists have somewhat of a bias that
everything is kind of simple and then
they think life is really really
difficult so it has to be rare in some
sense
um I I think that's not correct uh but
of course I don't know now if you're
asking about any particular type of
evidence I have to admit I I haven't
followed this at all
personally I haven't encountered any
particularly
um you know convincing evidence
um but yeah I hadn't really looked into
it
now are you in the camp or perhaps not
in the camp of those like our mutual
friend Eric Weinstein who suggest things
such as uh the fact that we should
devote some substantial resources to the
investigation of the phenomenon because
it might reveal new physics that could
then be used to solve many predicaments
that we have on Earth namely how do we
get off the Earth without you know as he
says you know putting chemical oxidants
inside of a phallic shaped tube and
shooting it to Mars as as our friend
Elon wants to do but would you say that
if we did find evidence of not not just
alien life like slime mold on you know
on Proxima Centauri B but if we found
technological intelligent life that that
would open up
a new portal into physics uh that we
would otherwise be ignorant to do you
think that's even a conceivable Prospect
for Humanity well it's certainly
conceivable in in the sense that it's I
can't imagine it
um if the question is How likely is it I
have no idea I mean I agree that this is
something which we should investigate
now if if I think what we said was we
should invest significant resources
because it brings up the question like
how significant right what amounts are
we talking about uh and I'm not really
in the position to make that kind of
judgment uh as I said I haven't really
followed it I would I would generally
agree yeah I mean it's a really
important thing it's one of those things
where the payoff could be so huge
that it would be stupid not to look at
it right
yeah I think that that's absolutely true
uh as well and yet you know the question
of the the level of
um of fervor uh about it is kind of
unmatched by the evidence and I want to
run an argument by you that I've used um
other scientists that are you know more
involved with this
um you know phenomena and even the the
concept of it uh and that's this concept
called panspermia which was originally
it sounds dirty but it's not don't worry
we won't get our YouTube demonetized uh
but the uh the concept was that life on
Earth it doesn't solve the origin of
Life problem but it solves the origin of
life on Earth problem and that's by
these little objects called meteorites
by the way you can get your own
meteorite if you subscribe to my mailing
list Brian keating.com list and if you
subscribe to sabina's mailing list maybe
she'll send you like a theory or she'll
she'll she'll tell you that you're full
of gobbledygook but you should subscribe
to that Sabina hasenfelder has a
wonderful mailing list we'll put links
to that below well but um but the theory
of panspermia posits that life on Earth
originated because uh objects like these
meteorites had a chemical uh life uh
exist molecules or precursors to life or
even life itself and they can survive
and they can land on on the earth and
then that causes darwinian Evolution to
sprout right so that's the theory but I
invert that argument and I say if that's
true then we should see life on uh on
Europa or on Titan or on some other moon
or asteroid or something because this
we've had life on Earth for four billion
years uh it's it only took a couple
hundred million years for life to get
kicked off and often Earth gets hit by
meteor meteoroids and those blast off
these same chunks of Earth including
life and they should be floating around
the solar system for literally billions
of years and some of them should have do
land on Mars we know that they've landed
on Mars because we have stuff from Mars
that land on Earth anyway Sabina this is
a long-winded question but do you
believe that the lack of evidence of
life from Earth on another body in our
solar system can provide some Bayesian
prior on the existence or the ability
for panspermia to take place in other
words for life to get spread throughout
the cosmos as soon as it gets created
but of course in principle yes exactly
we don't have a terrible lots of
evidence about uh you know my my
microbial life on other planets like
we've just about made it to Mars or
maybe to the moon but what do we know
about the other planets and then there's
this whole issue about the habitable
zone right if you're only looking at
planet in the habitable zone
then this planet is it right
um so I'm not sure how useful this
evidence is
um it's certainly evidence and you
should you should include it into your
priors uh but you know it's totally
outside my research area
[Music]
thank you